RJ MICHAEL: Hello
everyone I'm RJ Michael.
I'm Director of
Games for Google.
And is my great pleasure to
introduce you today one Ray
Kurzweil.
Ray Kurzweil is one of the
world's leading inventors,
thinkers, and futurists,
with a 30-year track
record of accurate predictions.
He's called many things
by a number of sources.
He's called "the restless
genius" by the "Wall Street
Journal," "the ultimate thinking
machine" by "Forbes Magazine."
PBS selected him as one of
their 16 revolutionaries
who made America.
Kurzweil was selected as
one of the top entrepreneurs
by "Inc. Magazine,"
who described him
as "the rightful heir
to Thomas Edison."
Kurzweil was a
principal inventor
of the first CCD flatbed
scanner, the first omnifont,
optical character
recognition system.
He did the first omnifont OCR.
He did the first printed
speech reading machine
for the blind, the first
text-to-speech synthesizer,
the first music synthesizer
capable of recreating
the grand piano and other
orchestral instruments,
and the first commercially
marketed large vocabulary
speech recognition system.
This is the stuff that the
guy's done with his life,
with his career so far.
Among his many honors,
he's the recipient
of the National
Medal of Technology.
He was inducted into
the National Inventors
Hall of Fame.
He holds 20 honorary doctorates,
and he has received honors
from three US Presidents.
Ray has written five national
bestselling books, including
the New York Times best seller,
"The Singularity is Near,"
in 2005, and more recently
"How to Create a Mind" in 2012.
He is Director of
Engineering at Google.
He is now heading up a team
developing machine intelligence
and natural language
understanding.
He has also been a personal
hero of mine since I was young.
And he has this drive to
make AI happen at Google.
And I couldn't be more delighted
to announce to you guys
that, as of today,
I am now going
to start exploring the
entertainment and education
space directly with Ray Kurzweil
in his new organization.
And who knows where
this is going to go,
but it's going to be awesome.
Ladies and gentlemen, may
I introduce Ray Kurzweil.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY KURZWEIL: Thank
you, and thanks, RJ.
And now that you're going
to be working with me,
we have to work on your
enthusiasm a little bit.
And it's great to be at Google.
It's actually my first job.
I'll talk a little bit
more about what I'm doing,
but I'd like to share with
you some ideas about thinking.
I've been thinking about
thinking for 50 years.
First, I would like
to say a few words
about the law of
accelerating returns.
I won't say too much about
it, because many of you
have heard me talk
about it before,
but the law of accelerating
returns is alive and well.
It's not just Moore's Law.
I keep hearing people
say, well, Moore's Law
is coming to an
end, as if that were
synonymous with the exponential
growth of information
technology.
Moore's law was just
one paradigm among many.
When I first studied
this in 1981,
Moore's Law had only been
underway for a few years, which
is shrinking components
on an integrated circuit.
1950s, there were
shrinking vacuum tubes
to keep this exponential
growth going.
Gordon Moore originally
said Moore's Law
would come to an end in 2002.
Justin Rattner, the CTO
of Intel, now says 2022.
But he'll also show
you, in their labs,
the sixth paradigm--
three-dimensional,
self-organizing
molecular circuits
working, which will keep the law
of accelerating returns going
well into late of this century.
So what is the law of
accelerating returns?
It's not that everything
grows exponentially, or even
every aspect of
information technology.
We're speeding up
transistors, making
them smaller so the electrons
have less distance to travel,
so transistors were faster.
That was a sub-paradigm.
I always felt we
were going too fast.
The human brain is
actually very slow,
computes about 100
calculations per second
in the interneuronal
connections.
But it's massively parallel.
So there's actually a 100
trillion-fold parallelism.
There's 100 billion neurons with
about 10,000 connections each,
and that's where the
computations take place.
So it's a very massively
parallel, but slow.
So it uses very
little energy, and we
needed to move more
in that direction,
towards more parallelism
and less speed.
So speeding up transistors
was just one sub-paradigm.
And we already have taken
steps in the third dimension.
Many memory circuits are
already three-dimensional.
The law of accelerating
returns is not
limited at all to Moore's Law.
Moore's Law is one paradigm
among many in computation.
Computation is one
example of many
of the law of
accelerating returns.
So what exactly
does it pertain to?
It pertains to the price
performance and capacity
of information
technology, and every form
of information technology.
So in computation, calculations
per second per constant dollar
has been speeding up at an
exponential pace since the 1890
census.
But it's also true
of communications,
biological technologies, brain
scanning, modeling the brain,
being able to reprogram
biological data,
printing-- the
spatial resolution
of three-dimensional printing,
which is turning information
into physical
products-- these are
all examples of either price
performance or capacity
of information technology.
And I'll show you
this first example.
I mean, this is the graph I
had in 1981 of computation.
It's a logarithmic scale.
Every label level is
100,000 times greater
than the level below it.
And so this represents
trillions-fold increase
in calculations per second
for constant dollar.
Moore's Law is the
fifth paradigm.
But notice how smooth
a trajectory that is.
It really has a mind of its own.
It goes through thick and
thin through one piece.
And exponential growth-- the
second point I want to make--
is not intuitive.
If you ever wonder, gee,
why do I have a brain?
It's really to make
predictions about the future
so we can anticipate the
consequences of our action,
and the consequences
of inaction.
But those built-in
predictors are linear.
When we were walking through
the fields 1,000 years ago,
we would make a prediction-- OK,
that animal is going that way.
I don't want to meet him.
I'm going to go a
different route.
That was good for survival.
That became hardwired
in our brains,
but those predictors are linear.
And people still use
their linear intuition
about the future.
That's the principal difference
between myself and my critics.
We're both looking
at the same reality.
We have similar
judgments about it.
And if I thought
progress was linear,
I'd be pessimistic also.
And many things are linear.
Biology-- health and
medicine was linear.
That was still useful.
The life expectancy
was 19 1,000 years ago.
We've quadrupled it.
I talked recently to some
junior high school students
and pointed out they would
all be senior citizens
if it hadn't been
for that progress.
Life expectancy was
37 200 years ago.
Schubert and Mozart
died in their 30s
of bacterial infections,
and that was typical.
That's all been from
linear progress.
Exponential progress
is quite different.
In a linear progression, that's
our intuition about the future
goes one, two, three.
And exponential
progression-- that's
the reality, not of everything,
but of price performance
capacity, of
information technology,
goes one, two, four.
It doesn't sound that
different, except by the time
you get to 30, the linear
progression-- our intuition's
at 30.
The exponential progression
is at a billion.
And that's not an
idle speculation.
I mean, this is
several billion times
more powerful per
dollar than the computer
I used when I was an
undergraduate at MIT.
It's several
trillion-fold since we
started with the
1890 American census.
But again, look at how
smooth a regression that is.
Nothing has any impact on it.
The third point
I want to make is
that it's not just computation.
It really affects every form
of information technology.
And information
technology is ultimately
going to transform
everything we care about,
as a result of application
developers like yourself.
I mean that's what
drives it forward,
and I'll say more about that.
We could buy one
transistor for $1 in 1968.
I was pretty excited
about that because I
was used to spending $50
for a telephone relay
that could do that.
We can now buy 10 billion.
Cost of a transistor cycle has
come down by half every year.
That's a 50%
deflation rate, so I
can get the same computation,
or communication,
or biological
technologies as I could
a year ago for half the price.
Economists actually worry
about that because we
had massive deflation
during the Great
Depression-- a different reason.
There was a collapse
of consumer confidence.
But the concern is, if I
can get the same stuff--
and I'll talk about
three-dimensional printing
in a moment to include physical
stuff-- for half the price,
I'll buy more.
I mean, that's economics
101, but I'm actually
going to double my consumption.
And if I don't, let's say
I increase my consumption
in terms of bits
and bytes 50%, which
is a lot-- the size of the
economy, not as measured
in bits, bytes, and basepeds,
but as measured in currency--
will shrink for a
variety of good reasons.
That would be a bad thing.
But that's not what happens.
I've got 50 different
consumption charts like this.
This is bits of memory consumed.
We actually more than
double it every year.
There's been 18% growth in
constant currency each year
for the last 50 years in every
form of information technology,
despite the fact that you
can get twice as much of it
each year for the same price.
And the reason for that
is application developers
like all of you.
I mean, why weren't there
social networks eight years ago?
Was it because Mark
Zuckerberg was still
in junior high school?
No, there were
attempts to do it,
and there are
arguments-- can we afford
to allow users to
download a picture?
The price performance
wasn't there.
Why weren't there search
engines more than 15 years ago?
I wrote in the early '80s,
when the ARPANET connected
a few thousand scientists, that
this was growing exponentially,
would necessarily do that.
This would therefore
be a World Wide Web--
I didn't use that term--
connecting hundreds of millions
of people to each other, and
to vast knowledge resources
by the late '90s.
People thought
that was nuts when
the entire American defense
budget could tie together
a few thousand
scientists, but that's
the power of exponential growth.
That's what happened.
And I wrote that there
would be so much information
you couldn't find anything
without search engines,
and the computational
communication resources
needed for a search engine
would come into place.
What you could not
predict is that it
would be these couple of kids
in a Stanford dorm near here,
who would take over the world
of search among the 50 projects
that were seeking to do that.
I'm not saying everything
is predictable,
but you could predict
that search engines would
be needed and feasible
in the late '90s.
And Google was founded in '98.
So "Time Magazine" wanted
a particular computer
they'd covered as the last
point on this cover story
about the law of
accelerating returns.
It's right there.
And this was a curve I'd
laid out 30 years earlier.
So this is, in fact,
very predictable.
And in terms of
all my predictions,
when they're like this, in
terms of actual numbers-- price
performance or capacity
of different information
technologies-- they're
really right on the money.
If you Google how my
predictions are faring,
you'll get 150-page essay
looking at all the predictions
that I've made as of that time,
which was a couple of years
ago, including 147
that I made in the age
of spiritual machines, which
I wrote in the late '90s,
came out in '99, about
2009-- 78% were exactly
correct to the year.
And these were predictions
that were by decade.
Another 8% were
off one year, so I
called them essentially correct.
So 86% were correct or
essentially correct.
The ones that were
wrong, included things
like regulatory and
cultural issues.
Like, for example,
one that was wrong
is that we'd have self-driving
cars, which, in fact, began
a glimmer of working in 2009.
If I had said 2014, it
would have been correct,
because Google self-driving cars
have already gone 8,000 miles.
And Google's going to launch a
fleet of experimental vehicles
in Mountain View this year.
But it wasn't correct for 2009.
The number of bits we
move around wirelessly
in the world over
the last century--
there was Morse code, over
AM radio a century ago,
today's 4G networks--
trillions-fold increase.
But again, look at how
smooth of a trajectory is.
Internet data traffic
doubling every year.
Here's that graph I had of
the ARPANET in the early '80s,
and projected that out.
The graph on the right
is the same data,
but on a linear scale.
And that's how we experience it.
We don't experience it in
the logarithmic domain.
So to the casual
observer, it looked
like, whoa, World Wide Web,
new thing, came out of nowhere.
But you could see coming.
And biology, this has been
a perfect exponential.
The Genome Project
was announced in 1990,
was not a mainstream project.
Halfway through the
project, critics
blasted it, saying,
look, here it's halfway
through this 15-year project.
You've only collected
1% of the genome.
So seven years, 1%, it's
going to take 700 years,
just like we said.
My reaction is, we're at 1%.
We're almost done, because it's
an exponential progression.
[LAUGHTER]
And indeed, it was
done seven years later,
because 1% is seven
doublings from 100%.
That's continued since the
end of the Genome Project.
That first genome cost
a billion dollars.
We're now down to a
few thousand dollars.
But it's not just sequencing.
We can now reprogram
this outdated data.
And there are many
examples of that.
The Johnson Diabetes
Center, they've
turned off the fat
insulin receptor gene.
We have technologies
like RNA interference
that can turn genes off.
These animals ate ravenously
and remained slim,
and lived 20% longer.
I've worked with a company
that adds a gene to patients
with a terminal disease called
pulmonary hypertension, caused
by one missing gene.
They scrape out these cells
non-invasively from the throat,
add the gene in vitro,
inspect it got done correctly,
replicate it several million
fold-- another new technology.
So they now have millions of
cells with that patient's DNA,
but with the gene
they're missing.
Inject it back in the body.
The body recognizes
them as lung cells,
and this is cured, this terminal
disease in human patients.
There's an interesting
case combining
a number of different
exponentially growing
information technologies,
with this young girl who
had a damaged windpipe.
She was not going to be
able to survive with it.
So they scanned her throat with
noninvasive imaging-- spatial
resolution of
noninvasive imaging
is doubling every year--
that's an important technology
for reverse engineering
the brain-- designed
her new windpipe in the
computer using computer design,
printed it out with a 3D printer
using biodegradable materials,
then populated this scaffolding
with her stem cells,
using the same 3D printer,
grew out a new windpipe for her
and installed it surgically.
And it worked fine.
You can now fix a broken
heart-- not yet from romance.
That'll take us a
few more decades.
[LAUGHTER]
But half of all heart attack
survivors have a damaged heart.
It's called low
ejection fraction.
My father had that in the
'60s, and could hardly walk.
Now you can fix that by
reprogramming adult stem cells,
and rejuvenating the heart.
You have to be a medical
tourist, because it's not
yet approved here,
although it will be soon.
There are many other examples.
We could talk all
day about this,
but our ability to reprogram
this outdated software
is growing exponentially.
These technologies are now
1,000 times more powerful
than they were a
decade ago, when
the Genome Project
was completed.
They'll be another 1,000 times
more powerful in a decade,
a million times more
powerful in 20 years.
That's the implication of a
doubling in power every year.
Somewhere between that
10 and 20 year mark,
we'll see significant
differences in life
expectancy-- not just
infant life expectancy,
but your remaining
life expectancy.
The models that are used
by life insurance companies
sort of continue
the linear progress
we've made before
health and medicine
was in information
technology, which
is based on, basically,
accidental findings.
This is going to
go into high gear.
Life expectancy is a
statistical phenomenon.
You could still be hit by
the proverbial bus tomorrow.
Of course, we're working
on that here at Google,
also, with self-driving cars.
And three-dimensional
printing-- I
think we're in the
hype phase of this.
I've written about the
life cycle of technologies.
Usually early enthusiasts
who see the vision,
but haven't really calculated
the timing correctly--
and exponential
growth ultimately
becomes transformative,
but it actually
starts out very slowly.
You're doubling
tiny, little numbers,
like 1/10,000 of the genome
in 1990, 2/10,000 in 1991.
So the progress doesn't
come on schedule.
Disillusionment lets in, and
then you have basically a bust.
And then it comes
back, as we really,
truly understand
the true markers
of what it will take
to be successful.
This looks like
a young audience,
but you may remember the
internet boom in the 1990s.
If you had the URL dog.com,
you were a billionaire.
Then around the
year 2000, people
realized you can't
really make money
with these internet companies.
And there was the
internet bust, which
almost took down the economy.
But then it came
back, and today you
have internet companies like
Google, and Apple, and Facebook
that are worth hundreds
of billions of dollars.
And we're kind of in
that hype phase now.
I think we're still five or six
years away from the parameters
we need to make this successful.
We need sub-micron resolutions.
The resolution
accuracy is improving
at a rate of about 100
in 3D volume per decade,
so it's exponential progress.
But right now,
it's multi-micron.
We can do interesting things.
We had an opening a year ago
at Singularity University
where the band-- all the
instruments that the band was
playing were printed out on
three-dimensional printers.
So there are interesting
niche applications.
But by 2020, we'll be able
to print out clothing,
for example.
So people will go-- great,
there goes the fashion industry.
But not so fast.
I mean, look at other
industries that have already
undergone the transformation
from physical products
to digital products.
A few years ago, if I wanted
to send you a book, or a movie,
or a music album, I'd
send you a FedEx package.
Today, I can send you
an email attachment.
And there is indeed
an open source market
with millions of free songs,
videos, movies, books,
documents that you can
download legally for free.
And you can have a very good
time with these free media
products.
But people still spend
money to read Harry Potter,
or go to the latest
blockbuster, or get music
from their favorite artists.
And you have the coexistence of
the open source market, which
is a great leveler, bringing
high-quality products
to everyone at almost
no cost, or no cost,
and a proprietary market.
That'll be the nature of
the economy going forward.
So in the 2020s, you'll be
able to download cool fashion
designs, print them out
at pennies per pound,
which is what it costs for
three-dimensional printing.
But people will still
spend money for the latest
hot designs from their
favorite designer.
And I mentioned
I've been thinking
about thinking for a long time.
50 years ago, I
wrote a paper when
I was 14, how I thought
the brain worked.
There was actually
very little to go on.
But I described it as
a series of modules,
and each module could
recognize a pattern.
And the essence of the human
brain was pattern recognition.
We actually weren't very
good at logical thinking.
Even then, I could see that
chess computers were based
on logic, and being able to
look ahead, and calculate
all the kind of move sequences.
The human brain did it by deep
forms of pattern recognition.
In '97, Kasparov was asked Deep
Blue analyzes 200,000 board
positions a second.
How many do you analyze?
And he said, maybe
less than one.
So how is it that he was
able to hold up at all?
It's his deep powers
of pattern recognition.
And I described it as a series
of modules, each of which
could learn a pattern, remember
a pattern, implement a pattern,
discover a pattern.
And that these were
organized in hierarchies,
and we created that hierarchy
with our own thinking.
And that the whole neocortex
worked the same way.
And that was actually
contrary to the common wisdom
of the time, because
it was noticed
that these different
regions, and they
do very different things.
So it was thought they must
be organized very differently.
V1 in the back of the head
recognizes visual images,
because that's where the
optic nerve spills into,
and it can recognize the fact
that the edge of this table
is flat, that there's
a horizontal crossbar
in that capital A, and so on.
The cruciform gyrus up
here recognizes faces.
We know that because
if you conk somebody
over the head in that
region, and knock it out,
people can't recognize faces.
The frontal cortex is famous for
language, and art, and science.
They do very different things.
They must be using
different algorithms.
There was one neuroscientist
who actually did
autopsies of the neocortex in
all of these different regions,
and found they looked
exactly the same--
the same neurons, the same
interconnection patterns.
He said neocortex is
neocortex-- Vernon Mountcastle.
And so I use that.
And I also use observations
of human brains
in action, which is still
our best laboratory,
and described this basic method.
This actually describes
the same algorithm,
and actually describes
how each of these modules,
which I count now
at 300 million,
can recognize a pattern,
learn a pattern.
It's basically
functionally similar
to a hierarchical hidden
Markov model, which
is a technology I worked on the
1990s, and speech recognition,
and early forms of natural
language understanding.
And it's a little bit
different than neural nets,
because neural nets-- the basic
element is a neuron, which
can kind of learn one state,
not really a whole pattern.
And in my view, the basic module
is a pattern-recognition module
that can learn a
more complex pattern.
And a hierarchical
hidden Markov model
is a hierarchy of Markov
models, each of which
can learn a fairly
complicated pattern.
I believe that is how
the human brain works.
And that's what I'm
doing here at Google.
I've given an early
version of this book
to Larry Page a
couple years ago.
He liked it.
I met with him to ask him for an
investment in the company I was
going to start to
develop these ideas.
And he said, have you thought
of doing this here at Google?
We have these terrific
resources in terms
of data, and
computation, and talent.
He actually said it
in a very low key way,
but that was his message.
So I met with
him-- Alan Eustace,
who's here in the audience.
They said I'd have the
kind of independence
I'd have with my own company,
but these Google resources--
and so I've been doing that
now for a year and a half.
And it's been terrific.
It's really the only place I
could do this project, which
has been a 50-year endeavor.
And the spatial resolution of
brain scanning, as I mentioned,
is doubling every year.
We can now see inside
a living brain,
see it create your
thoughts, see your thoughts
create your brain.
And there's a few
significant milestones
in the history of the biological
version of this thinking.
You see it up there--
the neocortex.
The neocortex emerged 200
million years ago with mammals.
It was capable of a
different type of thinking,
basically hierarchical thinking.
Other animals
could learn things,
but not with
elaborate hierarchies.
They could have a
behavior that might
have a hierarchical aspect
to it, but it was fixed.
They couldn't learn
a new hierarchy--
at least not in one lifetime.
Maybe over 10,000
lifetimes, they
could evolve a new behavior.
Next significant thing that
happened-- 65 million years
ago, there was a violent
change in the environment.
We call it the Cretaceous
Extinction Event.
That's when the
dinosaurs went extinct.
That's when 75% of all the
animal and plant species
went extinct.
And that's when mammals
overtook their ecological niche,
because they could adapt
their behavior quickly enough
to cope with it.
Next significant milestone
was 2 million years ago.
We developed these
large foreheads,
so we now had more neocortex.
That neocortex has all
these folds and convolutions
basically to increase
its surface area.
It's a flat structure.
It's about the size of a
table napkin and just as thin.
It's one module thick, but
it has so many convolutions
and ridges, it's
80% of your brain.
And the frontal cortex--
it's often been thought
it must be
qualitatively different,
because it does these amazing
things, like art and poetry.
But recent research projects
discovered, or examined,
the issue, what happens
to V1, which I mentioned
is in the back of the head, and
does these very simple things,
like the fact that that's
a straight line-- what
happens to it in a
congenitally blind person?
They're not getting
any visual images.
Well, the frontal cortex notices
hey, V1 isn't doing anything,
and it actually harnesses
it to help it with language,
and art, and science-- at
the opposite extreme end
of the continuum of
complexity of features,
showing that they're
both basically using
the same algorithm.
And so we are already doing
a very good job as primates
without the frontal cortex.
Now we had this
additional quantity,
and so we could think
higher thoughts.
Because the neocortex is
built on conceptual levels.
Each level is more abstract
than the one below it.
So the first thing
we invented was
language, and that was about a
couple hundred thousand years
ago.
So I have an idea in my head.
It's a hierarchy of
other ideas, and symbols,
and other structures.
And I want to actually
communicate that and basically
transmit that hierarchical
structure to your neocortex.
So we invented language
in order to do that.
And it's a communication
medium that is hierarchical,
so it could reflect the
hierarchical structures
in the neocortex.
The neocortex was
successful because the world
is hierarchical.
That's the best way
to understand it.
Trees have limbs.
Limbs have branches,
branches have other branches.
Some branches have leaves.
The world is organized in
a hierarchical fashion.
And we could now represent
this in language.
And if you ever want to see
some entertaining examples
of the hierarchy in language,
read a Gabriel Garcia Marquez
novel.
He has one sentence
that's six pages long,
and it's grammatically correct.
And it has a fantastic array of
hierarchical structures showing
the indefinite hierarchy we
can create with language,
reflecting the
indefinite hierarchy we
can have in our ideas.
And there's then been a
continual acceleration
of technology.
Written language only
took a few thousand years.
The first examples were
thousands of years ago.
The printing press took 400
years to reach a mass audience.
The telephone reached a quarter
of the American and European
population in 50 years.
The cellphone took seven years.
Social networks, wikis,
and blogs took three years.
We continually are
accelerating, basically,
these information
technologies because
of the law of
accelerating returns.
And we can now simulate
aspects of the neocortex.
And fundamentally what
my team-- and we're not
the only team doing
this-- is trying
to create a functional
simulation of the neocortex.
And I'll tell you
the key problem
is we can create hierarchies.
So even in the 1990s, we had a
hierarchy of acoustic states,
and then phonemes,
and then word models
for speech recognition, and
then simple grammatical models,
so that we could have a sentence
like, Move this paragraph to
after the third paragraph
in the next page.
And it would carry out
that simple command.
But we couldn't actually
add a new layer ourselves.
That's actually, if you
want to speak technically,
the key technical challenge in
trying to create more and more
flexible AI, is how do we
create the next conceptual level
that's more abstract than the
ones we have, automatically
from the data, rather than
reprogramming it ourselves
using our human intelligence?
I'll skip some of this to--
at the very high level,
you have very abstract
ideas, like that's funny,
that's ironic, she's pretty.
This 16-year-old girl
is having brain surgery.
And whenever they stimulated
these points showed in red,
she would laugh.
They wanted to be
able to talk to her.
There's no pain
receptors in the brain,
so you can do that
during brain surgery.
And they thought they were
stimulating some kind of laugh
reflex, but they quickly
realized that no, they
were triggering the genuine
perception of humor.
She just found
everything hilarious
whenever they
simulated these points.
You guys are so funny
just standing around,
was a typical comment.
And they weren't funny, so--
[LAUGHTER]
So an example from
another company
that shows our beginning
ability to actually understand
human language is WATSON.
As you can see, WATSON
got a higher score
than the best two human
players in Jeopardy combined.
It got this query correct
in the rhyme category,
"A long, tiresome
speech delivered
by a frothy pie topping,"
and WATSON quickly
said, "What is a
meringue harangue?"
And WATSON got its knowledge by
reading 200 million documents
of natural language,
including all
of Wikipedia and
other encyclopedias.
It doesn't understand each
page as well as you or I,
but it makes up for that
by reading a lot of pages.
And that's the kind of thing
we're trying to do here.
We have a model that
I believe actually
will solve this key
problem of being
able to add to the
hierarchy automatically,
so that we can handle,
ultimately, complex documents.
So one application,
for example, would
be in language translation.
Right now, it does a very good
job through the power of data,
and these Rosetta Stone
databases of translated text.
By matching word
sequences, we're
improving the way
that we match them.
But we really
would like to do it
the way a human does it,
which is to understand it.
What does it mean to understand?
It means to take the
language, and actually
create this
hierarchical structure
of the ideas in my head,
and then resynthesize it,
re-articulate it in
the new language.
That's the kind of
thing we hope to do.
We'd like the search
engine to read for meeting.
So if you put out a tweet,
"Everything Ray Kurzweil
is saying at I/O is
nonsense," there's
actually, in that simple
text, a hierarchy,
which you need to understand
to really understand
what that's trying to say.
If you write a blog post,
you have something to say,
and the search already
goes substantially
beyond the base forms.
It will understand the
syntactic structure.
If you see the
word "he," it'll do
that co-reference resolution.
It'll understand synonyms.
But it's not fully
modeling the ideas
that you have to say when you
write an article or a blog
post.
And that's what we would
like to actually understand.
And then you would
be able to dialogue
with your search engine
to give it complex tasks,
and interact with it the way you
would with a human assistant.
And it would then go out.
And maybe it wouldn't even
find the information that day,
but a week later,
would pop up and say,
you asked me this
question a week ago,
and new research just came out
that answers that question,
and so on.
So let's stop here, and I notice
that time clock isn't working,
so I have no idea where we are.
But RJ, maybe you've
got some questions.
RJ MICHAEL: Yes, indeed.
So I've gathered
up some questions
from people, fellow Googlers,
from some of our friends
throughout the community.
And we're going to
take this opportunity
to ask some of these
questions, starting
with a quote from
William Gibson,
the famed author who said
that, the future is here.
It's just unevenly distributed.
Where do you think
things are running fast,
and where they
lagging further behind
than what you would
have expected?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well,
I think it's actually
very widely distributed.
Companies like
Google-- and not just
Google-- Apple,
Microsoft, Facebook--
are not just using
these technologies
with a few corporations
and government agencies.
It's in billions of hands.
Google search is used by
between 1 and 2 billion people,
and we hope to expand that to
the next couple billion users
and a couple billion after that.
That's the business
model, and I believe
that is actually how we
will use these technologies.
They'll be very
widely distributed.
And they're very democratizing.
The technologies that
move very smoothly
are the sort of pure application
of the law of accelerating
returns.
When you get into
regulatory issues,
like we have with the
self-driving cars, maybe
a little less predictable.
There's a lot of
regulation in medicine.
But I believe these
technologies ultimately
will be so profoundly superior,
that they will actually
accelerate these regulatory
processes as well.
RJ MICHAEL: So you
outlined in your book, "How
to Create a Mind,"
the idea of what it's
going to take to
actually create a mind.
And you've chosen to pursue
these ideas here at Google.
Why Google?
RAY KURZWEIL:
Well, it's actually
the first time I've done that.
But I've realized that you need
unique resources to do this.
It's a very difficult problem.
So for one thing you need a
tremendous amount of talent.
That's, I think, the primary
resource that's unique--
maybe not completely
unique, but it's certainly
evident at Google.
And then you want
to run something
on a million computers, and
you want tremendous data
that reflects language.
And we have tens of
billions of pages--
virtually all books
and web pages.
And so this is not a project I
could do with my own company,
even if I raised all the
money that I could hope for.
And it's a bold company that
takes on major challenges,
and tries to improve the
world with these applications,
and make them widely available.
So I like the philosophy
of the leadership.
RJ MICHAEL: Me too.
It's true.
But I'm an engineer at
heart, and the engineer in me
wants to know how you
intend to build this thing.
Could you describe to us what
the engineered mind is like?
What tech must we
implement versus
what behavior do we
expect to emerge?
What must be done in software?
What must be done in hardware?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well, on
the hardware requirements,
I mean, to functionally
emulate the human brain--
I've analyzed that.
I've estimated it about 10
to the 14th calculations
per second and
singularity is near.
So I hedged that a bit and
said 10 to the 14th to 10
to the 16th.
I've reanalyzed it using
different methods in "How
to Create a mind" that come
up again with 10 to the 14th.
There've been a number of
independent analyses of that.
They come with the same figure.
We've already surpassed that
by three orders of magnitude
in supercomputers.
It'd be hard to provide 10
to the 14th calculations
per second to all
of a billion users
kind of using it more or
less at the same time.
I've discussed this
with Larry Page,
and he thinks no, actually
that could be possible.
But the law of
accelerating returns
will make that easy
by the early 2020.
So it really comes down
to a software problem.
I described, I think,
the key software problem.
We can already create
these hierarchies.
In Google, and in
other companies,
there's debate between several
different learning methods,
and they have pros and cons.
We need one that can actually
represent hierarchies
of complicated patterns,
where each pattern has
its position in a complicated
hierarchy of patterns.
And the key unsolved
problem is, how do we then
add a conceptually more
abstract level to that?
And I think we can
use machine learning
to find the patterns
at that high level,
but you need to be able
to model them correctly.
And so that's what
we're exploring.
And then applying
it to language.
And ultimately,
Google will apply it
to other types of input,
like videos and pictures.
And we're already making
a lot of progress.
Machine learning at Google
is already very powerful.
Once we have a system
that's working,
there will be little loops
that are very tight that
are taking up the bulk
of the computation
that we could put in
an ASIC, in a dedicated
circuit, because you can get
1,000 fold increase in price
performance by hard-wiring
repetitive algorithms
in hardware.
But and there are attempts,
of course, to do that.
I think it's premature now,
because we haven't really
settled on the right
type of machine learning.
So we don't really know
what algorithm to speed up.
But that'll be a straightforward
engineering trade-off,
once we can actually
mess with the software.
So it's a fundamentally
a software problem.
RJ MICHAEL: So most of
the people in this room
are engineers, or are heavily
involved in app development
as well.
And everything that you're
talking about here, these
are exciting visions to
a lot of people here,
and myself as well.
But what can the
developers in this room
do to turn these ideas of
yours into actual working
products and systems?
What role do these developers
play in pushing all of this
forward for us?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well it's
application developers
that drive it forward.
And I mean, there's
a debate in the AI
field between traditional
artificial intelligence,
and something called
AGI, Artificial General
Intelligence, which is
implicitly a criticism that AI
has not pursued
general intelligence,
and it's gone often
to narrow things
like OCRs, speech
recognition, or robotics.
But I actually think we get
from here to there-- there
being future AI, strong
AI-- one step at a time.
And the steps are
applications, and we
need to actually
optimize the technology
for the applications.
It's very hard to
develop a technology
if you don't have something
to optimize it for.
So I like the idea
of crossing the river
kind of from one
stone to the next.
People say, what about
that part of the river
where it's too deep,
and there are no stones?
So I'm not sure
the answer to that.
But we do get from here to there
through one step at a time.
And each step is sort of benign.
It's exciting in the
application world,
but it's not the
grand step to AI.
But that's how we're
going to get there,
and the application
developers push it forward,
and make it practical, and
provide an economic business
model for it.
RJ MICHAEL: So this law
of accelerating return
that you talk
about-- you've made
it clear in natural space,
that it exists like this.
And in a technology space,
it's definitely true.
It all starts to feel
just like natural law,
like natural progression.
Why do we have to
work toward it?
Why don't we just sit back
and let it happen for us?
RAY KURZWEIL: Yeah, that
question comes up a lot--
why don't we just sit
back and let it happen?
Why are we working so hard?
And if we did that,
it wouldn't happen.
So what is actually predictable
is the human passion
to make improvement, to
use the computers of 2014
to create the computers of 2015.
We couldn't do
that a decade ago.
And we're able to improve
things in an exponential manner.
Things are 1x.
We try to make it 2x.
If they are 1,000x, we don't
seek to make it 1,001x.
We try to make it 2,000.
And we have the
tools to do that.
I have a mathematical treatment
in "Singularity is Near."
The empirical data is
the strongest evidence
for the law o
accelerating returns.
But it is driven by application
developers and technology
developers taking each step with
the current state of the art.
RJ MICHAEL: And speaking
about the curves,
and the rising curves-- sorry,
I lost my place on my page here.
Well, so let's talk about
specialized smarts, then.
There's a role for
specialized smarts,
and the neocortex seems to have
a very general architecture--
repeated architecture,
as you were mentioning--
but there also seems to
be specific modules that
have evolved.
Do you think that there
are specific functions
that we're going to need
to build for our learning
machines?
And how do you know when
to go really specific,
and focus on one particular
thing, versus just allowing
it to be handled by the
general architecture?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well, we
still have the old brain,
like the amygdala puts out an
ancient cascade of hormones,
to prepare us for
a fight or flight.
It's no longer
able to decide what
to be afraid of, so your
boss walks in the room,
and whether that causes
laughter or fear is really
up to the neocortex.
And the neocortex is a
general architecture.
There are no
specialized regions.
There's no music region.
But the patterns
in music, or even
particular types of
music-- whether it's
Chopin waltzes, or hip-hop-- are
specialized types of knowledge.
And we have a limited
capacity in neocortex,
so you can really be a
world-class master of one
thing.
Einstein played the violin,
but he was no Jascha Heifetz.
Heifetz was
interested in physics,
but he was no Einstein.
We really need to devote
the bulk of our neocortex
that's not devoted
to every-day concerns
to one type of knowledge, which
has its own type of patterns,
and learn the patterns
that others have created,
and then push it forward.
But really, the architecture
is pretty much the same.
RJ MICHAEL: I find
that fascinating.
It's the same
algorithm repeated.
So while it's
great for all of us
that personal
technology has been
freeing us up, and
empowering us all,
giving us a lot more
free time, and giving us
more capabilities
under our fingertips,
do you think that
we are actually
going to make good use of it?
The thing that I
keep wondering about
is are we essentially going
to use this free time, and all
these extra capabilities that
computers give to us, to allow
us to watch more television,
and consume more sugary snacks?
Which is what I'm afraid of.
So how are we going to use
this technology that you're
developing, to ensure that
we actually will live better?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well, there's
always pros and cons.
We just happen to be on
the right slide here.
And this is just
one perspective.
People quickly lose perspective.
We forget what things
were like eight years
ago, before there were
social networks, 15 years ago
before there were
search engines.
Once these things
happen, we assume
they have always been around.
People certainly forget what
things were like 200 years ago,
when Thomas Hobbes
described life
as short, brutish,
disaster-prone, poverty-filled,
disease-filled.
Let's take a quick,
one-minute trip
through the last two centuries.
These are countries.
The big, red circle is China.
It does some interesting things.
Keep an eye on that.
The x-axis is income per
person in today's dollars,
so you can understand it.
So there were wealthy
countries and poor countries,
but nobody was very wealthy.
Income per person was hundreds
of dollars in today's dollars.
On the y-axis is
life expectancy.
In the '20s and '30s--
worldwide average, 37.
So this was the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution, started
in the textile industry
in England in 1800.
A few countries are
making progress.
But as you get to the
20th century, the 1900s,
you'll see a wind
that carries all
of these countries towards
the upper right-hand corner
of the graph.
The have, have-not
divide does not go away.
There's still rich countries
and poor countries.
But the countries that are worst
off at the end of the process
are far better off
than the countries that
were best off at the
beginning of the process.
And I shouldn't say
end of the process,
because the process
isn't ending.
It's going to go
into high gear as we
get to the more mature
phases of the biotechnology
and three-dimensional printing
revolutions, AI, and so on.
RJ MICHAEL: That's just awesome.
RAY KURZWEIL: So
to be continued.
RJ MICHAEL: So, and I think we
might have a few minutes left
to take some questions from
the audience at this point.
If--
RAY KURZWEIL: Well--
RJ MICHAEL: There's
two more left to ask,
but I'm saving those
babies for the end.
Unless you have something
you wanted to address.
RAY KURZWEIL: I don't know
how much time we have,
because the countdown
clock isn't working.
RJ MICHAEL: Yeah, the
countdown clock stopped.
We have two minutes left?
Oh, two minutes.
RAY KURZWEIL: OK.
RJ MICHAEL: All
right, well, then, I'm
going to stick to
my questions, then.
Sorry, you guys.
Because I've got
one that is just
want of my favorite
interview questions,
that have been
dying my whole life
to ask Ray these questions.
So if you would
tell us please, what
are some of the more
humbling experiences
you've had researching
and developing
your concepts over the years?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well, I think
it's this one unsolved research
question, that the human
brain is able to do,
and I think it's the key
to making further advances
in artificial intelligence.
The neocortex is
organized in these layers,
and each layer is more
abstract than the one below it.
And we're able to actually--
if we understand something,
like we understood
speech recognition,
we can actually identify
phonemes should be here,
words should be here, and we
can create that hierarchy,
and then use machine
learning to learn each level.
But how do we then create a
more abstract level on its own?
Because the neocortex does that.
I've been watching my grandson
go through level after level.
Now he's almost three, and
he's got quite a few levels
under his belt.
And that's done
with the neocortex,
without really any external
input, other than his parents
saying, that was good, Leo.
So how do we do that?
That's what we hope to solve.
I think we can have a
stable set of hierarchies,
and then find patterns at that
level using machine learning,
and then automatically
add a new level.
But that has never
been demonstrated,
and if we could do
that, I think we'll
make great strides in
artificial intelligence.
But so far, that has
eluded the AI field.
RJ MICHAEL: So then
I'll end with this--
you mentioned your
grandchild, three-year-old.
There's certain definitions
of the word consciousness
that would suggest that a
three-year-old has not yet
achieved consciousness--
awareness of self,
awareness of what's in a
mirror, and things like that.
RAY KURZWEIL: Well, he
would disagree with that.
But--
RJ MICHAEL: So I would
like to end, then,
with three simple
questions, that I would
ask you to take all
together for us.
What is consciousness?
What is free will?
And what is soul?
RAY KURZWEIL: Well,
I always thought
you had a good sense
of humor, so one minute
should be plenty for that.
[LAUGHTER]
We've debated that for
thousands of years,
going back to the
Platonic dialogues.
But to summarize,
consciousness--
whether or not an entity--
[LAUGHTER]
Whether or not an
entity has consciousness
is not a scientific
question, because there's
no experiment you could run
that would really definitively--
falsifiable experiment
that you could run,
whether or not an entity
is conscious or not.
We assume that each
other is conscious,
that human agreement
falls apart when
you go outside of
human experience.
People disagree about animals.
They will disagree
about future AIs.
An AI could claim
it's conscious.
Eugene Goostman claimed
that he was conscious,
but it wasn't very convincing.
And so you actually, but,
so some scientists say,
well, it's not a
scientific question.
It's not important.
We should dismiss it.
It's just an illusion.
I think that's a mistake,
because our whole moral system
is based on consciousness.
So you need a leap of faith.
My leap of faith is that if
an entity seems conscious,
and seems to be having
the subjective experiences
it claims to be having,
I'll believe it's conscious.
I will also make an
objective prediction
that most people will
accept the consciousness
of these entities.
And so a valid Turing Test--
I mean, I have a long, now,
Turing Test bet with Mitch
Kapor that by 2029, a computer
will pass the Turing Test.
And we actually set a very
difficult set of rules.
I think if an AI passes that,
people will really be convinced
that it's really conscious,
and we will accept it
as having those
subjective experiences.
Identity is really a
continuation of a pattern.
People say, what are
you talking about?
Your identity is this,
you're physical stuff.
It's this flesh and blood, but
actually this is very different
than it was six months ago.
All of our cells turn
over, some in hours,
some in days, some in weeks.
The different components
of the neurons,
the tubules, the ion
channels, the filaments,
change over in either
hours, or days, or weeks.
I'm completely different stuff
than I was six months ago.
So I make a comparison
to water in the stream.
It may make that certain pattern
as it goes around a rock.
That pattern can stay the
same for days, weeks, years.
But the water actually
changes in milliseconds.
So is that the same river?
There's a Chinese proverb, you
can't walk in the same river
twice.
But it's actually a
continuation of a pattern.
And that's what we are.
The pattern changes slowly,
but continuation of pattern,
even if we introduce
non-biological elements to it,
we would be continuing
that pattern.
And free will, that's
impossible to define.
I'm not convinced
I have free will.
Major decisions like
starting a project,
coming to work at
Google, speaking at IO--
did I really make that decision?
What was I thinking?
They just seem to
happen on their own.
I do actually think
a lot, and I think
I do have free will deciding
what to eat for lunch,
so I think making
eating choices is maybe
the heart of free will.
So I'll leave it at that.
RJ MICHAEL: OK,
that's very good.
Thank you so much, Ray.
You did just awesome.
Thank you so much.
Excellent.